[Música]
puede que cultura sea desde casa pero
hoy nos hace viajar hasta el prado el
museo español ha creado sin duda una de
las exposiciones más relevantes de este
primero porque de forma inédita en 201
años ha desconfiado del almacén a
ciertos artistas para tratar en 17
secciones la imagen dada a la mujer y su
condición de artífice en la pintura pero
en ese intento de disculparse y abordar
el machismo ha tropezado generando algo
mejor un debate no es que no se crea que
la genialidad era un prejuicio contra
las artistas o que el desnudo era
sexualización y maltrato es que queda
anacrónico para explicar la mujer desde
el hoy hacer ruido que de 130 obras
setentas sean de hombres incluso la de
abrir que se presentó erróneamente como
de mujer o el propio título invitadas
que suena a permiso que hay que dar a
las artistas el prado hace un gran
ejercicio pero podía haber asumido más
responsabilidad en esa falta de compra y
exhibición además que se vanaglorió
sobre otros museos cuando lo hace
también intentaré describir las
pinacotecas rosa pérez y querían lo
busca lo vieron de cerca
el museo del prado' entona el 'mea
culpa' es la intención de la exposición
temporal invitadas una reflexión sobre
el trato dado a las mujeres en el arte
en nuestro país esta pregunta estaba
sobre la mesa y era necesario contestar
que había pasado con las mujeres
artistas en particular en el siglo 19 y
era necesario que el museo del prado' se
preguntara sobre cómo está representada
la mujer en su colección la exposición
se divide en dos partes por un lado el
rescate de las artistas olvidadas en los
almacenes por otro la revisión de la
misoginia en el arte de los hombres
avalado por el estado
el mensaje moralizante de estas pinturas
estaba muy por delante de su categoría
artística a la hora de que el estado los
asumiera como propios y los validar
dándoles premios y adquiriendo los para
la colección pública una exposición
esperada que ha generado debate ha
cumplido las expectativas con creces que
aparte de bonita osa visualmente es muy
bonita y pues es instructiva es muy
educativa me ha sorprendido que una
parte de la exposición sea sobre todo la
visión de los hombres sobre las mujeres
una crítica compartida por las teóricas
del arte con
nada feminista como la del colectivo
mujeres en las artes visuales ha habido
muchas exposiciones sobre la imagen de
las mujeres y muchos seminarios y
catálogos etcétera con lo cual tampoco
me parece una gran novedad y creo que la
parte que todo el mundo estaba esperando
era la puesta en valor de las artistas y
creo que esa puesta en valor no se ha
conseguido porque lo que se ha
reproducido es la poca estima que había
que tuvieron en su momento sólo 11 de
las más de 1700 obras expuestas en el
prado son de mujeres invertir más en las
artistas y revisar el discurso del museo
desde nuestros tiempos es lo que
defiende en su último libro el autor de
las invisibles un museo es levantado por
ideologías por intenciones y por
intereses de hecho han disparado todavía
hay cuadros del siglo 19 cuya propaganda
no ha sido desactivada ese es el trabajo
del historiador contextualizar esos
cuadros que no están contextualizados
invitadas estará expuesta hasta marzo
será entonces cuando sepamos si la
autocrítica del prado es temporal o
permanente
sobre producciones recomendamos tres
iniciando por de queens gambit que le
pasa a lo que un north o docs parece una
miniserie discreta sobre una joven
talento del ajedrez pero en realidad es
un fenómeno quien no escuela la jugada
es año taylor joy en la piel de vez un
personaje que por un lado se explica
como un niño adolescente de un orfanato
de kentucky donde no sólo se hace adicta
a los tranquilizantes sino que
desarrolla su don el dilema es que el
autor de la trama walter davis creía que
el genio se paga y es así como la vez
aniñada va y viene dentro de una vez
adulta que es un ajedrecista prodigio
pero también un ser atormentado su
partida es entre 64 casillas y la vida
unas veces las domina otras haya
humillación y se pierden su psicosis por
ganar que crece cómo crecen sus rivales
y su inestabilidad emocional el
movimiento de esta miniserie cual
apertura gambito de dama es que el
ajedrez se hace sexy visualmente explota
las miradas de taylor y hoy dibuja en
imagen sus procesos mentales
contar que es una reivindicación de la
mujer en un mundo de hombres puede que
te viste basar en jugadores tipo bobby
fischer pero vez se los devora como se
devora esta joya de scot rank
my faith hills
ya que no sabe
perdón
[Aplausos]
[Música]
tal vez
de una novela también surge de andoín
que gana por una realización y unas
actuaciones impolutas baby tight que lee
de nuevo con nicole kidman no llega a la
psicología debilitan lines pero ha hecho
un thriller de tensión efectista en el
kit man el psiquiatra y hugh grant
oncólogo su dúplex su éxito laboral y
hasta su matrimonio transmite en la vida
cómoda que llevan pero un homicidio en
del entorno escolar de su hijo para que
sus secretos estalle revelando su doble
moral y la de quienes lo rodea
[Aplausos]
por último con decir baby yoga lo
decimos todo la nave del manta loria de
no pedro pascal se pone en marcha como
no segunda temporada sino como una
continuación de capítulos desde un
noveno episodio mo williams seguirá su
búsqueda tras el niño con la incógnita
de si estará boba fin mientras que el
legado llegáis seguro chocara con la
orden del guerrero cuyo primer sable
manda loria no ya vimos que lo tiene
idioma
desde esta web en otros temas el cubit
19 ha vuelto a rotar el mapa cultural
latinoamérica es hoy foco de aperturas
museísticas con buenos aires permitiendo
visitar el mamba el fernández blanco y
en la recta en bogotá además de museo se
suma el teatro julio mario santodomingo
con conciertos que van del género
concerto grosso hasta la ópera mientras
que los artistas urbanos o siemens
dieron color a la pinacoteca de sao
paulo desterrando el gris de siete meses
de cierre y trazando una línea que diría
aquí se generan sueños para escapar de
lo de afuera
afuera hay tristeza y es lo que sufre
europa con rebrotes y nuevos
confinamientos la escena musical del
continente está ahogada los cines piden
ayudas cuando en estos cuatro meses en
españa hubo 0,1 por ciento de contagios
en espacios culturales si bien a cada
medida se tambalean sitios como el museo
londinense de charles dickens el 150
aniversario de la muerte del autor debía
haber sido distinto sin jornadas
reducidas a tres días sin
estrangulamiento económico ni el 40 por
ciento del personal ha logrado reabrir
por varias subvenciones que han cubierto
500.000 de 850 mil libras anuales
la cuestión es que esos ingresos son
independientes
y llegamos a la parte que cada año nos
cuesta editar en contexto de tantos
brujas y difuntos ligado al virus un
grupo teatral mexicano ha reescrito la
leyenda de la llorona para que busque a
quienes murieron por la enfermedad su
espíritu de negra cabellera asusta desde
hace cinco siglos pero esta vez su
reaparición va dedicada a los que no
pudieron despedirse de sus seres
queridos
méxico venera la muerte y dinamarca le
hace un museo a las brujas y no es
baladí en los siglos 16 17 100.000
personas fueron procesadas por brujería
en europa y 50.000 fueron quemadas 10
salas de exposición reviven esta cacería
que se nutrió de una sociedad
supersticiosa y que no sólo castigó por
magia a mujeres también a hombres
en general tanto en dinamarca como en el
resto de europa la mayoría eran mujeres
pero también a diferencia de lo que la
mayoría de la gente piensa hasta uno de
cada cuatro eran hombres la mayoría de
las condenadas eran mujeres de edades
avanzadas que vivían al margen de la
sociedad y eran bastante pobres anchos
sanchis juanco de todo ello hay clásicos
de sobra y algunos se readaptan de
widgets ya tienen nueva versión de la
trama de ruanda hecha por guillermo del
toro alfonso cuarón y robert zemeckis
más cómica que la de los 90 y con
texturas más plásticas ganan el intento
de convertir a niños en ratones
[Música]
el nivel terror sube con la noruega
cadáver dejarán brian hutton en un mundo
post apocalipsis nuclear una familia
hambrienta acepta ver una obra de teatro
en un hotel con comida pero el escenario
cambia cuando empiezan a desaparecer
personas
hablando el otro otra el colofón es
house de remy weeks la trama sigue a una
pareja de refugiados que huyen de su
hogar y llegar a un pueblo británico
pero la monstruosidad ya no de la guerra
los perseguirá de forma real y
fantástica
la otitis
en casa
con sangre y lágrimas dice el grupo
royal blog que ha creado el siguiente
single hacía tres años desde la
oscuridad de su disco de 2017 que los de
brighton no sonaban así que disfruten de
su regreso y cuídense muchas gracias
[Música]
nunca